our enemies have have included that
America has a pres president who's a bit
of a weenie so now I want to show you a
video of Senator John Kennedy who is one
of our last remaining great Senators uh
from Louisiana of course and here he is
explaining now because as you can see
there's a push to somehow get gazin
refugees here it's so bananas it's
ridiculous um here he is explaining how
wokeness has actually degraded our
ability to basically do anything right
when it comes to this Administration I
think we need to ask ourselves though
Martha why are we here and I think we
have to be honest with
ourselves um America has a pres
president who is uh who is not a defense
Hawk uh America has a president whose
administration is frankly more
interested in
discussing whether a man can breastfeed
than it is is in talking about National
Security put yourself in the shoes of
our enemies Russia and Iran and China
what do they see they see an America
whose president cut and run from a
Afghanistan our enemies see an America
whose president refuses to give Ukraine
the weapons it needs to win our enemy
see in America uh whose pres president
refuses to enforce the sanctions on
Iranian oil and indeed has tried to give
the
Iranians um over not $6 billion but $10
billion I could continue but the point
is our enemies have have included that
America has a pres president who's a bit
of a weeny on National Defense and she
and Putin and the Ayatollah think they
can roll over him like uh like thunder
on a summer night and that's I think why
we're here peace through weakness never
works these are hard
men they interpret being a nice guy
quoting Socrates to them they interpret
that as a weakness and that is what this
Administration has been doing it's been
quoting Socrates to our enemies when
we're in a
barfight that's the way I see it yeah
it's like yeah he's right think of all
the time we've wasted on bathrooms and
whether third graders should be reading
pornography and everything else we've
completely taken our eye off the ball
instead of focusing on the basic stuff
the basic stuff have a border have Law
and Order would that be pretty good I
think that would usually be pretty
good